what scene from the big bang theory had
mayam bialik feeling immensely stressed
out and self-conscious keep watching to
find out what happy character moment
felt like a nightmare for the actor the
big bang theory was one of television's
longest running and most successful
sitcoms starring johnny galecki jim
parsons kaylee cuoco and mayam bialik
among others the show featured a bunch
of nerds stumbling through life and love
trying their best to find their own
personal happiness the show was adored
by millions of fans worldwide during its
run running for an astonishing 12
seasons before finally coming to an end
in 2019 but making the show wasn't
without its difficulties for bialik
especially when it came to filming the
show's iconic wedding scene bialik
played the brilliant dr amy farrar
fowler who meets dr sheldon cooper
played by parsons on an arranged date
she and sheldon start out a bit rocky as
tends to be the case with most
relationships sheldon gets into
throughout the show romantic or
otherwise but as they get to know one
another their budding friendship
eventually turns into something more she
makes him a better man and once he
finally matures just enough to realize
that he proposes at the end of season 11
amy and sheldon finally get married but
while fans of the show were jumping for
joy behind the scenes it was extremely
difficult for bialik to pretend to be a
smiling happy bride in a blog post
published on grok nation the night
before the episode aired she revealed
that it really affected her on a
personal level because as a divorced
woman it's hard to revisit that moment
in those decisions she also revealed
that prior to filming the scenes she had
been out sick for a month the illness
was treated with antibiotics which
promoted weight gain she wrote that she
quote felt ashamed and that she felt
like people were judging her weight in
appearance despite the fact that she had
no control over it she wrote even though
everyone said i looked beautiful i
didn't feel completely beautiful feeling
down and out regarding her appearance
during her wedding episode of the big
bang theory wasn't the only issue bialik
had to contend with like many performers
bialik had been open about her battle
with anxiety she spoke about it at
length during a 2021 episode of her
podcast bialik breakdown while speaking
with her big bang theory co-star kevin
sussman bialik said with acting stuff my
level of anxiety surrounding performing
is um
very very high
and unfortunately it's only heightened
when she does improvisational acting
something she was called upon to do
occasionally on the big bang theory she
explained and when i've tried to do
things like improv things that are very
kind of free form i freeze i literally
freeze it's like an instant knot in your
throat it's stuck and there are tears
there like i want to cry many other
celebrities including ryan reynolds and
emma stone have also opened up about
dealing with anxiety as individuals who
have to perform for a living even for
the most successful stars it's not easy
and bialik went on to discuss how
specifically it impacted her time on big
bang theory i've had this a handful of
times when working on big bang theory
when there was a certain way they wanted
a line delivered and i was like oh okay
i got that i'll do that in the next take
and i do it but it's still not right and
sometimes it's like the audience isn't
laughing you know it's not funny i can
usually do about four takes or five
takes before my throat starts to do that
thing while discussing her social
anxiety bialik revealed on her youtube
channel that she has made the decision
not to take medication i choose to to
live with it and to struggle through it
and and to find new ways that i can feel
freer to be myself
fortunately there are other ways in
which bialik manages her anxiety she
revealed that she goes to therapy and
practices meditation she's also a big
fan of weighted blankets it may have
been tough fortunately resources are
available to those who struggle with
anxiety and bialik was able to do
phenomenally during her time on the big
bang theory
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]